if you want to do great things you need
to be surrounded by greatness you need
to be surrounded by people energy ideas
that make you be the best version of
yourself so it created the environment
video series not to watch this video
full out but to have it as the
background of your life to have it on as
you are driving to work to have it on as
you are sitting at your desk to have it
on as you are relaxing to absorb the
wisdom the knowledge the energy the
creativity to help you go out and create
great things I hope you enjoy here's the
goal and whatever it takes to get there
I will do
so I was doing my daily work cleaning
the guns and going to the shooting range
marching 20 miles a day and rolling
around up hills with weapons running at
5:00 in the morning with heavy combat
beats and all of this stuff and then
everyone just almost drops dead at night
he's totally exhausted I worked out
three hours and got up early the morning
again to do my sit-ups and push-ups and
my chin-ups there was a clear conflict a
dilemma because the lifting was not the
traditional sport for them they didn't
like the idea they didn't even have the
equipment I had to go and figure out
every way possible to do dips between
chairs over the bar across two chairs
and good upset down rowing everyone
would say this is the wrong direction
that I'm going or I'm in a dream world
and I'm useless whatever it was I said
I'm gonna break through that no matter
what it takes I needed to reach that
core that vision that I had of being a
world champion
who would have thought in all of the
years of the Oprah show the Jim Carrey
would be one of our greatest teachers I
think it's really a marvelous thing that
visualization thing you did do I read
about this I hear this that you used to
go up on Mulholland Drive and play every
night and visualize seeing yourself is
yeah I would visualize yeah broken polar
right having directors interested in me
and people that I respected saying you
know I like your work or whatever that
is and and I would visualize things
coming to me that I wanted or whatever
this was in like 1987 85 yeah and I had
nothing at that time so it was like but
it just made me feel better it made me
at that time all it really was for me
was kind of making me feel better I
would drive home and think well I do
have these things and they're out there
I just don't have a hold of them yet but
they're out there so didn't you write
yourself a check I heard that you did is
that true wrote myself a check for ten
million dollars for acting services
rendered and I gave myself five years
there three years maybe and and I dated
it Thanksgiving 1995 and I put it in my
wallet and I
kept it there and it deteriorated and
deteriorated and stuff and and but then
just before Thanksgiving 1995 I found
out that I was gonna make ten million
dollars on thinking food Dumb and Dumber
how can other people tap dance to work
what's the secret of it you find your
passion you find your passion I was very
very lucky to find it you know when I
was seven or eight years old and you
know and fortunately my children have
found their passion might you know one
son loves farming like nothing else one
son loves music like everything else and
all three of them love philanthropy and
what they get to do you're lucky in life
when you find it and you can't guarantee
you're gonna find it your first job out
but I always told college students that
come on I say take the job that you
would take if you were independently
wealthy
you know that's you're going to do well
at it if you think you're going to be a
lot happier if you've got to X instead
of X you're probably making a mistake I
mean it guys in he oughta you ought to
find something you like that's that
works with that and it and you'll get in
trouble if if you think that making 10
extra 20 X is the answer to everything
in life because then you will do things
like borrow money when you should endure
or maybe cut corners on things that your
boy want you to cut corners on ER it
just doesn't make any sense you won't
like it when you look back on it happen
Wayne's a very curious person and and
that curiosity really is I think at the
bases for all the kinds of things that I
like to try and experiment with and and
attempt and and we have a good time
doing it it's not it's not so much being
driven as much as being interested in a
lot of different things how you see it
whatever the truth is your perception
and how you see a truth outweighs that
10 to one so it's a motivation and why
you're doing it you know it's in a
journey of getting in shape it's a long
long run right
the person who's standing at the end
with their hand raised isn't the person
with all the genetics it isn't the
person of the most potential it's the
person that has the greatest
perseverance that's always willing to
get out the difference between a
champion and a loser is that the you
know they both fail and says the loser
allows the failure to stand for life
with a champion even though he gets
knocked on his ass fahncy tests boards
who to stand back up reface that
endeavor until it becomes his favor
until he wins that's the difference
champions get back up and do it again
and a difference between stolen and
successful here are some of the
spectator here is that a person is
successful you know they believe in
themselves so much and their belief
overrides any crowds disbelieve think
big because then you're gonna get big
then you're gonna go and achieve big
things that is the most important thing
you know we don't achieve big things by
accident so shoot for the top shoot for
the sky for the you know for the stars
and when I say life doesn't happen to
you it happens for you I really don't
know if that's true I'm just making a
conscious choice to perceive challenges
as something beneficial so that I can
deal with them in the most productive
way you'll come up with your own style
that's part of the fun three things and
hiring people looking for an integrity
intelligence and energy and he said if
that person didn't have the first two
that the latter two would kill them
because if they don't have integrity
you want to dumb and lazy you don't want
them smart an energetic when you develop
your business plan don't be afraid to
write everything down everything that
comes into your mind because ultimately
if you have a good business plan
well-thought-out
well-designed carried out for a year or
two or three you can start to follow
that plan and an orderly fashion does it
always work it doesn't always work it
doesn't always turn out the way you
think it's going to turn out you might
stumble or trip or fall in a gully but
if you have the plan you can get up and
continue on your path yeah be a student
you know what nutrition is what
supplementation is why you're training
you can't be a blind squirrel trying to
find the nut every day meaning you have
to know what you're doing you know if
your body to change it starts at the top
of the greatest muscle why you're doing
what you're doing if you're not in the
game then you don't understand the ins
and the outs of each daily operation all
of those liabilities that they talked
about started turning into assets when
it had Conan the Barbarian the director
came to me and he said if we wouldn't
have you people don't have to build one
and then Terminator the director said I
couldn't imagine to have anyone played
terminated it wouldn't have an accent
and they wouldn't have your body I
cannot imagine the line I'll be back
with a normal American accent it works
so perfectly than you have this German
accent so all of those things that they
say the liabilities became an asset the
moment as moment went on they grew and
grew and I went from one movie to the
next started making more and more money
and then an aunt ended up being the
highest-paid actor with 30 million
dollars on Terminator 3 all my life I've
really wanted to do this so it doesn't
seem like I've been in the business for
a short time that's all I've ever wanted
to do it's all I've ever done it never
bothered me
if people disagreed with what I thought
as long as I thought I knew the facts I
mean there's a whole bunch of things I
don't know think about I just stay away
from those so I stay within what I call
my circle of competence you know that
Tom Watson said it best he said you know
he said he said I'm no genius but I'm
smart in spots and I stay around those
spots well I try and stay around those
spots and I I just don't have a problem
if somebody says you know you're wrong
on something I just go back and look at
the facts and I think that I think that
really is much more important frankly
than having a few points of IQ or having
an extra course or two in school or
anything of the sort
you need emotional stability I really
encourage them if they have a great idea
to run with it
find way
to to finance find ways to build find
ways to market success has nothing to do
with potential it's all about the
perseverance of somebody that will
override any endeavor if you throw
against the wall eventually something
will stick you guys that are had this
potential don't have a special you know
that's dies what continues to last
forever is a perseverance always show up
that's what champions do every single
champion the same as every ordinary
person knowing differentials that they
show up to the event every single day
they see failure as a learning curve
they welcome failure you learn more from
failure than you ever will from success
so showing up and get knocked on your
ass
finally test 1:40 to stand back up
Andrea they said endeavour it's gonna be
the overriding factor that makes a
difference how do you know when you're
doing those things the small things in
life add up to those big monumental
things why send a small things it's a
character building block that your name
means something you hold value to your
name if you drop trash on the ground you
pick it up that's the responsibility you
hold value to yourself when you shake
someone's hand you look them in the eye
give me a firm handshake because you're
here for a purpose everything you do you
do to the best of your ability
doesn't know what you're doing is it
that that you're doing it so therefore
it means something to you that's gonna
build a legacy because you know the
title out there doesn't mean you win the
title fine that title will not get you
another title while you're trying to
build its legacy you know footprints
behind you there are left motivation for
someone else to follow legacy is built
daily through the character the
willpower the code of conduct within
some life and that's the perseverance
showing up every single day that will
always achieve the goal it doesn't
matter what you're born with it doesn't
matter potential how much you know a
silver spoon of money you have all that
can be attained if you show up and
you're willing to to risk failure for
success that must be the same
bodybuilding intention haut zeigen
technique she came on to be a young
hunter almost in max okay
our Lord once the rhymes lady neither
the fontanel done house this way I get
the unit C average my father he said
this is an embarrassment to me and was
stomping all over me just this an insane
belief in my own ability to manifest
things insane a belief you know that I
think it's ultimately complete sanity
but I believe we're creators and I
believe we create with every thought and
every word is every moment is pregnant
with the next moment of your life I just
read and read and read I probably read 5
to 6 hours a day I don't read as fast
now as when I was younger but I read
five daily newspapers I read a fair
number of magazines I read 10 Kay's I
read annual reports and I read a lot of
other things to the side I always
enjoyed reading I loved reading
biographies once you develop a large
customer base and we reach about a
hundred million people every month of
all our various businesses our books our
magazines or television and once you
develop that kind of close rapport
they have already a feeling that I'm
providing them with things that you
don't want so it's very important to
engender trust with your customer if you
disappoint them I mean if you make
something that falls apart forget it you
don't get that customer back again and
all I want to do is grow my customer
base I want to be where that customer
needs and once I went through the life
and the military sports and I always
used the gym for some means it was never
about fitness modeling I said passionate
for lucky now every time I hit struggles
or I'll stressed out I wasn't to the gym
to find solidity there and the work
through any kind of stresses so
naturally I got in shape but it wasn't
for a fitness model in those for the
military in sports and then later on
down the road an agency agency saw me
it's an age to take some pictures or no
try it that's how this was born but it
wasn't the starting I didn't start out
set off with us it just ended up coming
to pass
the other thing is is that you get to
work your butt off if you think that
you're gonna go and accomplish something
really special and be the best in
anything in the world and you think you
can do it without working you make a big
mistake because no matter what I did if
it was a body building or an acting or
if it is in the political arena it
always took a lot a lot of work and you
gotta put out and you got the you know
something to make a lot of sacrifices
notice if you're not willing to work
hard forget about it so there's another
rule that is very important you will
already know who you are and that piece
that piece that we're after lies
somewhere beyond personality your need
for acceptance can make you invisible in
this world don't let anything stand in
the way of the light that shines through
this form risk being seen in all of your
glory
they must lesson about a margin of
safety that you don't drive a truck that
weighs ninety nine hundred pounds across
a bridge that says limit ten thousand
pounds because you can't be that sure
about it if you see something like that
you go down a little further down the
road and you find whether it says limit
twenty thousand pounds and that's the
one you drive across every business has
and and I don't like to think of things
as obstacles all the time I'd like to
think them as challenges to be solved
and and problems to be dealt with I
could teach you whatever you know but
when you go out there you try it
yourself and you fall flat on your face
that's what you learn at the most
because the next time when you fall you
learn to catch yourself and that's the
lesson you never forget so everyone
wants a wargame a man ever wants to sit
back and what is and before they start
the journey they want to plan it out war
game and wargaming
just get going man get going you're
learning along the way and some of you
wanna be a fitness model so trying to
figure out all fitness myself to be a
fitness model but you just fall in love
with a passion I know a lot of people
that started out to be a fitness model
but that wasn't a real passion but they
didn't know until I started it and now
that I like the photographer or the
editor or an actor coming up to LA then
now is a great producer or director you
don't know what the field is just get
going and figure it out you know and
then the truth will surface you know
action causes reaction you know if you
stand still in a sedative States you
know if you're a pond you know in
sedative what grows in there's algae
there mosquitos no one wants it but you
have a current you know a Palin or
something it's like in a waste it's
people want to come and look at it your
life has to be moving the same way use
your power of potential and make this
nation in this world a better place
it worked for this immigrant that came
over here to this country with twenty
dollars in the pocket and I know and I
guarantee it will work for you too I
have no education I had no high school
diploma I didn't even have it
I quit high school and halfway through
grade 10 I didn't have a lot of options
that would be a dishwasher or a waiter
custodial work of some sort so I decided
I might as well go and do something
creative I decided to go to the comedy
store the Laugh Factory in the improv
you know all all of those clubs every
night and make my 25 bucks a pop a set
it was my version of being later it was
a compromise I decided to make out of
that came in living color and out of
that came a touring auditoriums 5,000
seaters it was a really creative time
I was able to prove that I didn't have
to be an impressionist that I had a
personality my own however abrasive it
might be from time to time a long story
short all of it came from that
compromise from that deciding to do what
I didn't want to do things you can't do
or the things you're not allowed to do
look at the executives come and say you
can't do that whatever it is it's too
expensive you get angry you get out of
your mind about it because you've been
clinging to this concept in this image
that you have of how it should be done
and invariably most times after that
storm has passed
and you actually sit down and go okay we
can't do it that way how can we do it he
end up with something even better than
what was there before and you go
that's the universe that's how it works
just like relationships like everything
the thing that has taken away your
clinging to when you're trying to fix
you're trying to secure it make sure it
doesn't go away we think it your life
will be destroyed everything will be
ruined
and it's just universe goings no I have
something better for you I just have
faith sometimes compromise is actually
the way to get to what you want the
nature of capitalism is that people want
to come in and take your castles
perfectly understandable I mean if I'm
selling television sets or something
there's going to be ten other people who
are gonna try and sell a better
television set if I have a restaurant
here in Omaha people are gonna try and
copy my menu and get more parking and
take my chef and so on so capitalism is
all about somebody coming and trying to
take the castle now what you need is you
need a castle that has some durable
competitive advantage some castle that
has a moat around and that moat that's
one of the best moats in many respects
is to be a low-cost producer but
sometimes the motors just happening more
talent I mean if you're the heavyweight
champion in the world and you keep
knocking out people you've got a
competitive advantage as well if you can
keep doing it and it's very profitable
if you're the one that happens to be
able to do it if you can turn out great
motion pictures yeah I mean you know
Steven Spielberg I mean he he he's a
Feld to have been on and and it has
enormous economic value when I started
the business the Martha Stewart Living
Omnimedia our two words were inspire and
in
for so you create the beautiful picture
you create the lifestyle that you think
everybody would aspire to and then you
have to tell them that again so that's
the teaching part and maybe that inspire
that inspiration you have to know what
you can't fake it
so I learn every single day one of my
mottos is learn something new every day
and I do so it's it's all about
informing yourself so that you can be a
good teacher when you guys are sitting
on the couch or wherever you are
watching this to take that first step
towards greatness it's very hard that's
the hardest step of everything is that
first step right yeah that first step
towards greatness is hard
what's a lot harder it's when time
expires in life you look back on your
life knowing you could have been great
that's something you can't control
anymore cuz times run out I say they
wanted to get into acting people said no
you have an accent and you have a party
that is too big and you name no one can
pronounce be realistic it's the 70s
today Dustin Hoffman he's the big shot
Al Pacino little guys Woody Allen said
simple even when I ran for governor this
is are you kidding me I mean you can
never win give it up but I didn't pay
any attention because it myself what did
I do
when they said you can't go to German
you can't compete in a junior mr. Europe
that I did not listen to the no I went
and it worked out
and I use that attitude as a blueprint
for the rest of my life you are ready
and able to do beautiful things in this
world and after you walk through those
doors today you will only ever have two
choices love or fear choose love and
don't ever let fear turn you against
your playful heart you'd be surprised at
that my days I mean they are they're
very unstructured no meetings none I
mean I don't like meetings and I read a
lot
I wish over a faster reader you know I
get more done but i but I do read a lot
and I I I'm on the phone a moderate
amount our businesses run themselves
basically out there my job is allocating
capital and and I that's what I'm
thinking about but I don't like to have
things all packed hour an hour an hour
and and though I are both
extraordinarily lucky I mean we really
get to do what we would like to do the
way we want to do it with people that we
choose to be around then they're
terrific I mean we we've really got
everything our way and it's a we're very
fortunate and in his world he has some
he has a different kind of pace than I
have but we both love it the way we do
it and and my guess is that were each
the most productive in that particular
mode too because it it it fits our
personalities and and and aptitudes yes
no I refuse how do you well I think if I
cry but I don't cry in this you don't
find business no I don't think business
is worth crying over
I think you have to again concentrate on
business you can build your business you
can help others build businesses and and
its business it's not about emotion it's
about really going for it you can be
passionate that's that's the only
emotion I allow in my business I had the
greatest job in the world it's the job
where I get to put out what I do what I
love to do
and help to inspire people to do what
they love and achieve things I come
these Expos and people wait three hours
or even or drive ten hours or a plane
and they wait in these lines and they
come to me and they say thank you for
everything you're doing
you've always saved my life for your
huge motivation a huge difference and
they don't understand how much that
means to me
because that's the greatest thing in
life that's the legacy that you actually
do something to leave an impact towards
others and there's no greater honor than
that it's not until I come here and
someone takes time out of their day that
gives value to what I do you know they
use it to transform themselves to give
belief in themselves to change the light
to become the person they've always
wanted to be and they come they share
that and I thank me for that but the
thing is it's their sweat on their shirt
not mine I just help them believe in
themselves and they have a small impact
and a better betterment of their life
that just humbles me so much and so
that's why I think I had the greatest
job in the world because the return on
investment it's not a monetary value
what's the value that that builds legacy
don't be afraid to fail because if
you're afraid to fail then you're always
holding yourself back because you're
afraid that if you go all out you may
fail well in weightlifting we learned it
very quickly the only way you could
break a record is if you're willing to
fail that's when you put on more weight
you try it sometimes you maybe don't you
would not be able to lift it we just
happened to me many times but eventually
when you train hard enough you will lift
it so don't be afraid to fail you I mean
how far can you fall the total believer
yeah I believe in manifestation I
believe in you know putting a rocket of
desire out into the universe and and you
get it when you believe it you get it
when you believe you have it and that's
the key is like people still they sit
around going when's it gonna come when's
it gonna come when they're gonna come
when's it gonna come and that's the
wrong way you're your face in the wrong
way you're facing away from it you have
to go it's here it's here it's here what
kills great businesses if you look at I
do believe in looking at history and I
and I try to I like to study failure
actually and my partner says all I want
to know is where I'll die so I'll never
go there
and and we want to see what has caused
businesses to go bad and the biggest
thing that kills them
it's complacency I mean you you want a
restlessness a feeling that you know
that that somebody's always after you
but you're going to stay ahead of them
you always want to be on the move and
and when you've got a great business you
know like coca-cola wishes there aren't
any like oh girl but but really the
danger would always be the you rest on
your laurels but I see none of that
obviously a coca-cola but that's that
that is the key to compete the same way
when you've got 1.8 billion servings
being sold daily as when you were
selling you know 10 a day and and that
restlessness that belief that that
tomorrow's more exciting than today you
know you just have to have it permeate
the organization I have always said ever
since I started working that I am my
customer I want to appeal to me what's
missing in my life
what void can I fill that will fill the
voids for everybody that's like me and
my mother would always say nobody's like
you Martha forget it and I always said
mother I am like everybody else and you
know I have chickens I have a garden I
scrub the floors I vacuum my house I'm
just like everybody else
and so she finally got to understand
what I was talking about because I
always want to please me with what we do
do I want to buy it do I need it so it's
the need in the water not the dog in the
fight that matters it's the fighting the
dog that matters same with you it's not
your genetics or your potential it's how
bad you want it in Austria kids were
conditioned avowal parents path but
unlike other kids around me I was very
determined that I have to get out of
there
and then one day I saw the cup of a
magazine of reg Park then it says how
mr. universe became Hercules I opened up
this magazine and the red fluid and
there was the whole plan laid out ask
yourself
Arnold what is it about you that is so
different why are you the only one that
sees it so clearly the score going the
American winning the Mr Universe contest
and getting in the move is in making
millions of dollars no one else talks
about this around yes is it real is it
just a crazy fantasy but wait a minute
rich Park did it then it's possible
Arnold focused the key thing is to be
focused visualize the goal and I saw
myself standing up to the stage just
like rich Park and it became more and
more clear
Arnold you've got to go it's our
intention our intention is everything
nothing happens on this planet without
it not one single thing has ever been
accomplished without intention who was
Ben Grimm he was your primary mentor
model it was a wonderful man and he was
my professor at Columbia I read his book
when I was 19 at the University of
Nebraska and I started investing when I
was 11 I started reading about it when I
was like 7 so I'd gone through all I
read every book in the Omaha Public
Library that was on by the time I was 12
on investing in stock market and I had a
lot of fun but I never really found out
I never got grounded to anything and it
was it was entertaining but it wasn't
gonna be profitable and then I read
Graham's book the Intelligent Investor
when I was at the University of Nebraska
and pulled open the whole thing up to me
yeah and I and I named my my oldest son
is named Howard after my dad Graham
Buffett and then he was a marvelous man
I never expected anything from me in
return
Ben Graham in his low and his low teens
looked around and he looked at the
people he admired and he said you know I
want to be admired so why don't I just
behave like them and they found there
was nothing impossible about behaving
like them and similarly he did the same
thing on the reverse side in terms of
getting rid of those qualities I'm
working hard all day it'd be busy in the
kitchen cooking and makin for my video
efficient I need to leave this place
looking clean and fresh I'm Martha
Stewart so it has to be the best bring
on the bacon soda bring on the clean
this kitchen has to be ready for that
next big scene the fridge it's filled
with all my favorite food any funky
odors can really ruin my mood this box
here that was food tastes fresher longer
stops any odors from getting stronger
going to the gym it's not about like
checking the boss did you know paid my
dues today I go in there and I find it
it's self discovery you know it's like
there's something about that a threat
when you can't do it you know of who you
are when you're pushing it you're trying
to get it up and do we just quit
we just rack it or we racket drop the
weight and keep going for the burnin or
do we get someone to spot us who are we
in that adversity do we push past it do
we try to get more out of it or do we
settle do we say words like good enough
and if you do say good enough you're in
trouble because you don't know if you
have enough until later so I would say
if you never use terms like good enough
tomorrow you always have enough so I can
leave it all there when I work out and
that way no matter what happens later in
life my nose you know not because my
shortcomings done today you know those
three reps that could have done is that
the difference of me being successful
later I don't know that's why I do those
three reps so I never have to wonder
what it it just shows you again so much
for it can't be done this is my I try to
tell you anything and everything can be
done if you can visualize it and if you
believe in yourself it was the same
thing again when I ran for governor you
can imagine when I went on at the night
show and I announced that I'm gonna run
for governor of the great state of
California people came to me afterwards
and says you're crazy you don't announce
something like this under tonight's show
you have an official press conference at
the State Capitol plus you don't start
with governorship you go start first
with mayor or with state senator and I
said I don't want to be senator I don't
want to be mayor I want to be governor
don't you understand that well the rest
is history I won in 2003 and they won
also in 2006 let me tell you you're
going to find the naysayers in every
turn that you make
don't listen just visualize you cor know
exactly where you want to go trust
yourself
get out there and Brooke like hell and
break some of the rules and never ever
be afraid of failure you can spend your
whole life imagining ghosts worrying
about the pathway to the future but all
there will ever be is what's happening
here in the decisions we make in this
moment which are based in either love or
fear so many of us choose our path out
of fear disguised as practicality what
we really want seems impossibly out of
reach and ridiculous to expect so we
never dare to ask the universe for it
I'm saying I'm the proof that you can
ask the universe for it please and if it
doesn't happen for you right away it's
only because the universe is so busy
fulfilling my order
my father could have been a great
comedian but he didn't believe that that
was possible for him and so he made a
conservative choice instead he got a
safe job as an accountant and when I was
12 years old he was let go from that
safe job and our family had to do
whatever we could to survive I learned
many great lessons from my father not
the least of which was that you can fail
at what you don't want so you might as
well take a chance on doing what you
love you have given a lot of fabulous
advice but what's the best advice that
you've ever received well I I've
received in a variety of forms
particular my father when I was very
young but I mean he basically I think
taught me how to live not that I did it
perfectly or anything like that but I
mean he was giving me lessons but he
wasn't doing it by preaching to me he
was doing it by example but basically
well the biggest lesson in a sense I got
is the power of unconditional love I
mean I think there is no power on earth
like unconditional love and I think that
if you offer that to your child
I mean you 90 percent of the way home
and maybe days when you don't feel like
it it's not uncritical love that's a
different animal but but to know you
always can come back I mean that is that
is huge and right that takes you a long
long way and I would say that every
parent out there that that can extend
that to their child at a very young age
it's gonna make for a better human being
and you felt like you've got that kind
of unconditional love from your bed I
absolutely did you know that's a
powerful thing it is a powerful thing
well I worked really hard and I think
that that the working hard and have and
making money for your hard work that was
another thing that I also discovered as
an entrepreneur that oh it's all well
and good to work really hard but you
must be compensated for your hard work
and not be greedy about it but be
compensated fairly and that when you
look at the end of the month that you
actually have some money in the bank
that you could invest or reinvest in
your business
that you have actually succeeded and
being
a good business person as well and you
can pay your your associates and your
colleagues well you can really actually
see that a business is forming that a
business is being created that you are
actually being productive head of state
motive a guy's one get a partner
champions come in pairs of two because
they battle themselves in the defection
a partner is not only an asset to you on
the physical side but also the mental
side meaning when you guys are coming
home from work or something or maybe the
wife is just yelling at you too much and
that's kid you driving you into a
migraine where the kids are just you
know it's just one's days you know the
bosses on your he's like I just need to
go to the bar or something you know well
if you have a partner your partner some
corner amen buddy hit a gem you like
dude man I said a long day and
everything else and that's not feeling
man like on the gym you know and and so
you let him down now we can all fool
ourselves and barely the real truth
inside of us of why we're not going
right and kid ourselves for whatever
reasons are these excuses I mean nothing
but give them value give them weight to
make us not go so we can fail one our
own account but you got to be a really
low to fell on some weights relying on
you very few people will do that when
you make a commitment a verbal written
commit into somebody you're me and your
word means you mean something to them
when they call you up and say hey let's
go and you like to mail not into them
and I into it wow so you're not into it
not only affects you but also affects
someone else's state know what's gonna
happen that guy's gonna pull you into
the gym
drag your through the workout even
though you were old you didn't want to
and by expending that energy at tired
state you can come at it doing since a
pride relief well you know more found
energy like wow man that felt good
now you move back into your problems
that you didn't want to do that Jenkins
are overwhelming and you're gonna look
at them differently now I'm sorry you
guys see the problems with solutions
because your minds your thinking smart
you're thinking more more of the glass
half-full sets an empty you know and
you're gonna find remedies and solutions
those key problems makes for a better
day combined that fair to all of them
good week good month good year also
partners really key because you're gonna
have hit you're gonna tell you right the
partners we have use for scraps three
four reps those when pushing past
failure
you gonna feel that hi Wow then you feel
that pump you're gonna feel a lot on top
of that you guys have been going through
the same workout with Keynes right now
person a sa Joe is I'm going to person B
John and say man now that way you feel
like John you feeling it and John might
be like yeah man I'm totally feeling it
Joe goes well well John you know what
I'm doing wrong
yeah I think you're doing this way let
me try that oh you and I feel it so you
guys can get in push and pull off each
other on what is working what isn't
working
so you find a mental strength or you
like hey man John hey I'm really feeling
this but you know what I'm not seeing
the results as much um you know what's
your diet like what are you doing well
I'm doing this and doing that and you
guys start comparing each other you know
and you guys are feeding off what is
working what isn't working because you
guys are team partners are essential
guys if you don't know partner
you really can't push yourself past
certain limitations and so's force reps
and failures and drop sets and anything
else to really get the most bang for the
buck okay partner must be the partner
thank you guys so much for watching I'd
love to know what you think if you leave
a comment below continue to surround
yourself with greatness continue to
believe and I'll see you soon